you said garage sailing is one of the
best start right now business
experiences that you can go get it's
very practical so so I took it around
with it so I did that for summer I made
about five thousand dollars but this
snowballed into bigger opportunities so
I started with that then my brain
started to change yeah yeah
I need to know what was your best single
flip what did you buy for the least and
sold for the most yeah so amazing uh The
Amazing Spider-Man first appearance of
of Carnage I spent a dollar I sold it
for eighty dollars that that same day uh
I sold travel bags I bought two of them
for 15 ended up selling them for 300 so
I never had that like I still got that
throw of the hunt the amount of people
listening or the amount of friends of
the people listening right now that like
desperately could use fifteen dollars to
300 is like very real and I know right
now someone's like oh yeah but gas and
eBay piece I'm like cool 15 to 197 is
like a real win for a lot of people and
it is the thrill of the hunt and that's
why people we're going into that season
now it is absolutely garage sale season
Vayner Nation how are you a very very
very very special episode of the garyvee
audio experience as you know uh the
guests are more rare the original
content is more rare it's more chopping
and
figuring out and obviously working thank
you all for enjoying the podcast as a
matter of fact
in this opportunity being live with you
um for everyone who's listening to the
podcast I really do see all my tweets so
please hit me up on Twitter and put hey
garyvee the podcast and then finish your
sentence any way you want but I'll
search hey garyvee the podcast would
love to get your perspectives what you
like what's helped you I know it's
working but today's episode is really
kind of a meta thing I'm going to let
the uh guest explain it and then I'm
gonna jump on and tell you all while
it's why it's important
but um Jonathan why why don't you tell
the Vayner Nation how you got here give
us the whole story take the next two
three minutes and first tell us who you
are what you do but then tell us why
you're here
yeah yeah definitely so my name is John
Tory co-founder and director of
marketing at Searchlight so we match
data online activity to offline sales
for home service companies uh We've
grown rapidly over the past few years
and really this journey started about
four years ago in 2019 I was a product
manager at a technology company I had a
really great first part of my career but
I felt very stuck I was approaching my
30th birthday deep down I just knew that
I should be doing more I always have
that entrepreneurial Spirit but I didn't
know where to turn
and I was listening to one of your
podcasts and you said garage sailing is
one of the best start right now business
experiences that you can go get it's
very practical so so I took it around
with it so I did that for summer I made
about five thousand dollars but this
snowballed into bigger opportunities so
I started with that then my brain
started to change yeah yeah
I need to know what were your best
single flip what did you buy for the
least and sold for the most yeah so
amazing uh The Amazing Spider-Man first
appearance of of Carnage I I spent a
dollar I sold it for eighty dollars that
that same day uh I sold travel bags I
bought two of them for 15 ended up
selling them for three hundred dollars
so I never had that like I still got
that throw of the hunt I love it you're
outside you're talking to people the
first appearance of Carnage which I
actually was a comic book and baseball
card dealer at that point there was a
very short window when I was flipping
comics
in addition to cards and Carnage's first
appearance was the comic that started
that business because I bought 80 of
them
yep and like it really got hot Carnage
got hot
um so that's massive I love that story
but by the way the thrill of the hunt a
dollar going to 80 or 15 going to 300.
we're so caught up in the Elon Musk or
the Jeff Bezos
or this that and the other thing that we
don't realize how epic that is for so
many the amount of people listening or
the amount of friends of the people
listening right now that like
desperately could use 15 to 300.
is like very real and I know right now
someone's like oh yeah but gas and eBay
fees I'm like cool 15 to 197 is like a
real win for a lot of people and it is
the thrill of the hunt and that's why
people we're going into that season now
it is absolutely garage sale season we
need to do it but go ahead
yeah so so absolutely so I started there
but the taking that action and it's it
taught me business skills that actually
helped get Searchlight to seven figures
and we can go into some of that but that
turned into sports card trading so I was
walking through a mall I saw Carson
Wentz autographed helmet and I thought
this is interesting this is April if I
buy this now and he gets back to his MVP
form this is a couple years ago yeah I
could probably put that and then you
started talking about sports cards and I
thought oh that's a lot easier to store
I know the print runs things like that
so I got into sports cards right away I
built a nice little collection for
myself but it was during the boom time
so I was able to save a year of income
literally a year of income buying and
selling I got into the communities I
learned I know they don't like to talk
about it as investing things like that
but then that led me to writing for 1 37
pm so in February of 2021 I called DM
Tyler I had written two articles I wrote
a summary for him I said hey I I'd love
to do some freelance writing I applied
hadn't heard back so let me you know
demonstrate that value to you he got me
connected with Jay it took a couple
months I had to send you know follow up
with another article but they said hey
we love your your latest piece we're
gonna go live with it let's do this on a
more regular Cadence
so that turned into that and then a
couple months later you on the props and
drop podcast said hey if one of my
listeners writes the top 50 famous
failed card games
and publish it I'm going to share it
across all my social media channels and
because I had been writing for 1 37 p.m
I've been doing the list goals I was
more prepared than ever to take the bull
by the horns there
so I wrote it I I it was Saturday I was
in Burke Vermont I was with my friends
they were mountain biking so Saturday
I'm in this house alone because they're
mountain biking and I just started going
I wrote 50 ad at five you shared it
across all your socials and then what I
learned in that moment
was I need my own blog I published it on
medium.com you drove thousands of people
to like man I should have had a Blog I
could have captured email addresses this
could become a nice little little side
hustle and so two weeks later I launched
start with nfts.com
because of that experience like no I'm
not letting that pass up and you were
talking about nfts and uh you know I I
was kind of drawn to that from the
collectibility of sports cards I wrote a
couple curious articles which you
retweeted crypto Strikers you retweeted
then Tyler DM me and said hey man you
should write about nfts for 1 37 p.m and
I said sweet like how do you want me to
do it he said I trust you just find some
people to interview and and write some
stories so Ezra on your team Jeremy hone
uh the local weather team I got to
interview Matthew Lillard one of my
favorite actors he played Stu and scream
and he was so kind and he's like I love
garyvee I love I love that we're going
to do this so I really built this skill
set of writing and putting content out
there
but in between there
we started a little company called
Searchlight Advertising and at first we
were an agency in the Home Services
space doing PPC and Facebook marketing
we got a few clients it was nights and
weekends but I knew at my full-time job
they were gonna we're gonna get rid of
me at some point because I was remote I
was gonna go where my girlfriend is I'm
down in Raleigh North Carolina now
um and you know we grind it I mean
nights weekends we we had our first few
clients we delivered exceptional
experiences PE firms were coming into
the space and buying these companies
like crazy so the clients that we went
above and beyond for started to get
acquired and then the PE firm would fire
us and those clients would say no we
need this team uh to do this and we were
able to win some of that back but but
the biggest thing to connect us took a
garage selling for people
we had three accounts in our first six
months of business family friends just
hey we'll do this at a low cost we did
this in automotive for 10 years we care
about your business we're gonna help you
grow
one of the things that I discovered with
one of my clients that came back to me
and said hey Jonathan we we love your
team
we know that you care about our business
but we don't see the return on ad spend
in the CRM
and so for my eBay days what I would get
really detailed I would look at the the
sales comps and the details of the
listing if this Nerf gun has this
cartridge it sells for ten dollars more
so I want to look for that so I tracked
by hand
thousands of leads from lead to revenue
and we found a huge problem in the HVAC
Electrical Plumbing Industries which is
blowing up at the time really
accelerated by covid
so we built a solution around that and
we we're bootstrapped we found product
Market fit but the best part of all this
is we find this product Market fit now
we got to go tell the world about it
and I I super I use that writing
experience from 1 37 PM from medium.com
a lot of a lot of what you talk about
like everybody had a podcast everybody
had a Facebook group we had very unique
data we could tell you how customers
convert on the website the actual
customer acquisition costs it's a long
journey in HVAC you get an appointment
consultation you turn it into events so
we can track that better than anybody
even some of the big players that are
competing with us and I started the data
driven trades sub stack took me two
minutes it was about eight months in
when I have gotten multiple DMS on
LinkedIn a week John I love your content
let's talk I want to learn more about
how your billion dollar companies PE
firms
and we can't even keep up with them we
just uh partnered with a company called
chirp they do outbound you know get a
consultation send some text so we're
measuring the revenue there with our
capabilities and and that came about
because a client heard me on a podcast
they hired us then they hired chirp and
it's I've been blown away and it's all
of this you talked before about
ingredients and then cooking those
ingredients
garage saling writing on medium writing
for 1 37 p.m starting at Blog the
Arbitrage of the sports cards and the
garage sales all kind of culminated
seven figure business bootstrap six of
us full time and we're growing like
crazy at a time we're very empathetic to
you know the larger economy right now
but that's created more demand for our
data because it's been a lot harder out
there
amazing
so thank you
because your advice just taking it
running with it really helped well it's
it's the thing that I think about every
day even like having you on right now
it's like
there's six people listening to me for
nine years who now that you just said it
and it's not me saying it have decided
to do it
I thank you because without people like
you
it's not it's not fulfilling
you know I know what I'm putting out
I know what happens if people do it I
just know that 99 of people that listen
to me don't do it
right
you know there was this thing I would do
every couple years where I was like stop
listening to me right now like
unsubscribe from this podcast unfollow
me stop listening and go and I've met a
lot of these people who did it they're
like Gary I'm so pumped you told me stop
consuming me start doing and I met these
people the reason I don't do it the last
couple years is what happened was the
same people that wouldn't listen to the
advice and do anything about it thought
that stopping following me made them do
it but they didn't so I really [__] up
because they stopped getting positive
you know energy and Karma and they still
weren't doing it and instead they found
like bad versions of that energy and
like it's almost like like that's why I
stopped doing I'm like [__] this is
[__] it up it's like like that's bad
advice the good advice is doing what I'm
doing right now which is like my friends
everything you just heard is real like
if you do the push-ups you get the
muscles like I promise you
like let's just not make this historical
if you do Facebook reels right now three
a day instead of just doing Tick Tock
and Instagram I promise you you'll grow
much better on Facebook reels than
everywhere else and I don't care if
you're selling to 23 year old cool kids
if you title your YouTube shorts the way
that people search
on Google which oh by the way you don't
need any special tools go type in every
word any word HVAC I can type that into
Google right now forget about Google and
better analytics just typing it in
Google will populate 10 things that most
people type in in the bar
if you like a video on YouTube shorts
that's like a tick tock or an Instagram
reel or YouTube short but you title it
based on what people search your YouTube
short might become a video that leads to
a lot of business opportunities for you
just the YouTube short because unlike
Tick Tock and Instagram it's not like
ephemeral or it goes away after a day or
an hour it's kind of there because
YouTube's the second biggest search
engine
if you start a podcast if you post on
LinkedIn three times a day if you start
a Facebook group if you if you if you if
you eat more protein than carbs if you
work out every day if you sleep seven
hours a day you will lose 13 pounds like
you know what I mean like and so it's
it's huge that you're doing that and
what about getting on this podcast
yeah I mean getting on this podcast like
hey so I saw a tweet from you and I and
look like I pay attention so when we
talk about like right now because of the
an email newsletter right and I hear you
like we need to do video and we turn
into videos but it's my email newsletter
we are either working with or in
conversations or RFP with seven of the
10 largest private Equity firms and we
didn't exist as a business a couple
years ago uh but getting to this podcast
I saw a tweet where you you responded to
somebody and said it's my biggest
challenge that person sort of mentioned
hey Gary you you talk about doing all
these things but most people listen they
get hyped they flex and then it just
kind of dies off so I saw that and it
was for me the story was really just I
heard that you know I felt super stuck
and anxious about where I was at my
career in life so I just went garage
sailing I just went and I did it and I
and I loved it and I did it every single
weekend then it turned into sports cards
then it turned into writing for 1 37 p.m
somewhere in the middle there I got you
know a call like hey dude you're killing
it you should join search that out let's
grow this thing and and again all the
ingredients there helped but you and I
have interacted a bunch like you've
retweeted a lot of my articles because I
know what you like and you're interested
in so by the time I got to that five
minute face time with you because I
bought one of the slots from an nft
holder and I kind of prepared it's like
I I think I'm actually your perfect case
study because I didn't four years ago I
think I was gonna be able to do this
that was my goal is to inspire people
who listen to this but I just followed
it for four years didn't give up there
are a lot of times I wanted to but I
didn't and now it's like whoa like I
wake up in my life I moved from
Burlington Vermont to Raleigh North
Carolina I've got a new business I sold
the blog in less than 18 months I sold
start with nfts I went through that
whole process got myself a nice little
bonus and now if you ask people like all
of a sudden they're like John Tory came
out of nowhere in the HVAC space but you
need to subscribe to his content and
it's opened tremendous doors just from
written content in the context of what's
valuable to our customers and it was
just doing it
by the way John you know this because
you really do pay attention I talk about
the written
play as a real play yes do I think
people do Facebook reels I sure do but I
it's clear to me you very much pay
attention
I can't even imagine how many times
you've heard me say it starts with
self-awareness and if you're a great
writer just write be a blogger
like there's a lot of people that would
literally let me give you an example if
I wasn't if I was scared of the camera
if I was scared of the camera which many
people are they're insecure of how they
look they don't like it
and that was the only difference in my
life I'm just scared of the camera I'm
incapable of writing which is why I've
never been a blogger what I would do is
I would be an audio Monster audio
monster
I don't mean just a podcast I would turn
my audio clips or I would do memos on my
iPhone and I would do memos on my iPhone
actually what am I talking about right
now one of my best creative pillars in
my garyvee brand is just audio with a
visual on Instagram where it's just me
talking and we're doing word overlays
and like a nice little mountain in
[__] Vermont I don't know
yep yep we got to get the Vermont there
well so what I would do Gary is I would
go into these Facebook groups do that
they existed I don't want to compete
there that's just it's not my thing it
wasn't sort of my like that's not my
Superstar going to these Facebook groups
and every night I would just read the
comments because you talked about this
before too just read the comments get
the feel of people so I would people
would ask the same questions over and
over how do you deal with manual calls
what's your cost per acquisition what is
this what is that so yes I wrote These
articles but I answered the questions
that I saw over and over again in these
groups where these HVAC companies are
super brutally honest with each other I
was able to get in there and I just kind
of alert and and read answer the
questions then what we do is Elena on my
team she'll do the same thing we'll do a
visual of the data you know you can
click through we do video content we'll
do audio content uh we could be doing it
way more but just literally the new
header itself has been tremendous so
effective that I've actually had to go
and up with some of the onboarding and
and you know some of the partnership
work there because it's just it's it's
grown that quickly
listen
there there's nothing I'm more sure of
I'm more sure that content that scale
that comes from an authentic place of
either passion or knowledge at scale in
all formats in all the relevant
distribution channels
it I know that that is effective if you
do it for a year or two to create
unlimited opportunities I believe in
that more than I believe that the sun
will come up tomorrow
yep
from the five minute face times that
were part of my nft project because I
want everybody to hear all of this
because they may not be able to do it
with me but they may be able to do it
with many of the others that are people
like me
um yep in that like I believe that I'm
one of those people and then what
happens in that five minute Face Time
yeah so you know I you you had a fever
the night before so I knew going in I'm
like right Gary's probably tired so I
want to be succinct and and clear about
this journey I started from Step One
2019 hated my job was really freaking
out about to turn 30 like I felt
helpless and stuck not a great place to
be
serendipitously I was driving to
Connecticut to visit my girlfriend heard
your podcast where you said garage sales
great start right now so I took did it
then it turned into sports cards then I
actually started a podcast there's so
many different things I tried I started
a podcast interviewing UVM University of
Vermont alumni to talk about their
career Journeys we actually did a show
with a student where it was during covet
and she went through the process of
getting a job she got multiple offers we
document it then I went on to you with
garyvee with you and I asked like what
do you know how do I grow the podcast
and and what ended up happening from
there is I wrote how I got on t with
garyvee you retweeted it so I wrote for
medium and this is what I told you in
that call
told you about okay then I wrote 70
articles on me I got my writing chops up
made some money doing it and then from
there it was writing for 1 37 p.m then
writing the 50 famous film card games
then starting this blog and again all
behind the scenes doing the Searchlight
thing and growing the hell out of that
and I sit before you and and this is
what I said I think this is the not
angle but I think this is why you were
because I said I see you talk about how
you really want to see case studies
that's your biggest someone asked you
like what's your biggest need or what
would you like to see the most like I
just would love to see case studies of
people who take the things that are
relevant to them like I like the garage
sale I'm not doing it just because you
said it I liked it I loved it sports
cards the same thing and nobody I think
nobody's waking up at 5 30 to take 18
into 150 even though they need that 150
um unless there's some level of like the
thing that most people don't realize is
most of people listening right now don't
realize how much they're gonna like it
especially the people there's somebody
right now listening cliche cliche 48
year old dude fan of garyvee [__] with
me I [__] with you by the way Johnny big
shout out has a six-year-old daughter
has working loves his daughter plays
with her but doesn't have his thing with
his daughter yet you know what I mean
doesn't have his thing he has no idea
that if the Saturday after he listens
let's say he's I don't know when we're
gonna post this podcast let's say it's
Tuesday that if he right now Googles
while he's at work while he's running
while he's on a treadmill right now
takes his phone and Google's garage
sales around Gary Indiana because he
lives in Gary Indiana or garage sales
near me or downloads a garage sale app
on the App Store that shows him garage
sales around him comes home Tuesday
night says his six-year-old daughter
we're doing something this Saturday
morning you and me just daddy and
daughter time
plops her in the back seat and goes from
8 AM to noon and then has lunch with her
that the reason that AJ vaynerchuk and I
are such close Brothers is because
garage saleing yeah like
and so like a lot of parents don't
realize oh it's not this or they this or
they take them to things but it's not
quality time like you took him to karate
but you weren't with him when you're in
the car together for four hours
when you're driving 17 minutes to your
next garage sale and you ask your
six-year-old daughter hey why'd you want
me to buy that rabbit
she says something you get a little more
insight to her you say something you by
the way are such a good listener that
that would really work for you but like
I just don't think people realize what
I'm saying which is like hey a lot of
you listening right now could use an
extra 5 000 bucks this summer
hey this works every time if you do the
homework of searching on eBay what's
valuable it's not you do it 10 20 times
you get your chops up you learn how to
copyright headlines you learn how to
take photos you learn how to have
humility of like packing the boxes and
shipping it but most of all you're going
to get quality time with your under 10
year old because taking them to soccer
matches and then watching them is
amazing and talking about the game after
but being in a car together for six
hours
go into garage sales where there's a
million different things at these homes
that lead to conversations learned
interests shared interests if you watch
your child of what they're gravitating
towards you're like oh you like that why
like like I'll give you I'm just gonna
keep playing up this imaginary story she
picks up a badminton like racket
she thinks it's cute you're like oh you
like that you buy the [__] set for
three bucks you come home you put it up
in the afternoon now you're playing bad
like this is life
yeah
anyway I'm sorry I wanted to get that
out because to your point the whole meta
of this conversation I am desperate for
more people after this podcast to do the
thing
and I don't think I can be the only
Storyteller of it because they didn't
see me at 17 20 I said this to Dustin in
Asia I was like I wish I was
dramatically less successful so that
everybody would believe me more they
only see the end result right when I say
in my 20s that I was making less than
100K and working you know all these
hours and doing it for my parents they
he they don't hear me it's the same
reason when I when I was saying 99 of
nfts are going to go to zero people
didn't hear that they they heard it as
20 of nfts are going to lose 30 market
share they didn't hear 99-0
yeah
I mean when I quit my full-time job to
go to searchlight I made less than a
hundred thousand dollars and I lived
with my parents in South Philadelphia
for five months and ended up selling my
car I still haven't gotten a car again
and I love every second of it like like
in those moments you think I'm 32 and
living at home with my parents right it
didn't bother me at all because I I knew
where I was going but just to the point
that's so big you know I always talk
about don't give a [__] what they're
saying you said something right now that
I say but not as clear as you just said
I never was confused how the out I
always say I I said it in a brunch a few
minutes ago with a bunch of nft holders
I know how this movie ends I know what
the scoreboard is going to look like
when it hits triple zero
the reason you didn't give a [__] at 32
is the same reason I didn't give a
[__] 32. I knew where I was going
yep
and I have more data on it because you
asked me that five years ago to be like
well I don't know I had success in a
large company but then I started to get
data through the oh garage sales I'm
actually good at this so the writing
actually built an audience I got as I
got more data when I'm 32 working 15
hours a day you know my parents spare
bedroom like I I know where this is
let me tell you what's important about
the data you got it was affirmation on
Merit not based on subjective opinions
in a corporation
and that's always right you know you
know in a job right you're getting
Julian is going to get affirmation of my
subjective opinion and I'm a human
since Dustin's drocks it's flawed data
it could be it's fine but it's a human's
opinion
yep when you buy and sell on eBay when
you write articles the market decides
yep
and that's important because when I felt
stuck
I knew those subjective opinions I'm
like these people are undervaluing me
and they're overlooking me because I I
didn't get promoted for five years and I
was traveling across the country
presenting the Audi and a lot of these
big Brands like subjective taking for
granted they didn't even do it logically
sometimes sometimes managers owners I
say this because it's happened to me and
I watched it happen to a million people
sometimes it's not even quote unquote on
purpose
as a matter of fact I would argue the
best people live lives where they're
being taken for granted my kindness my
empathy my my generosity is always taken
for granted because people become used
to it
right
anyway we're wrapping this up I got I
got to go to my next thing unfortunately
but I think for everyone you could tell
why I wanted this man on I feel like
this episode is gonna get 16 of you off
your butt and 16 out of 150 000 is
better than zero out of 150 000. so
brother I'll give you the last few
seconds here if you want to shout out
anything or say anything or do anything
it's yours
no I mean just shout out to you Gary
everybody listening I I promise you like
just just try it out nothing better than
a Saturday morning when the sun is
shining and you're sitting thinking
about what Netflix show you're gonna
watch by the time then to go out do with
your friends like I would do with my
girlfriend and that brought us closer
together you're outside you get to see
all this cool Collectibles why do people
buy this why do they air about it why
are people paying all this money for it
as a way to get started because look at
what it turned in into for me
Searchlight Digital Dot IO I'm gonna go
take a look look at my LinkedIn and some
of the interactions and stuff that are
happening but Gary man I'm so humbled
that you made the time I know how busy
you are you made the time to let me tell
this story so my man I'm so grateful
listen honestly brother I'm being
selfish I want this for my community
because too many people just don't
believe it they don't think them I can't
work for him I'm not it's just not true
love you see ya bye everyone hope you
enjoyed this episode